>> HEY JOHNSON, DON'T FORGET, WE
NEED THOSE REPORTS BY THE END OF
THE DAY.
>> YOU GOT IT.
>> OH.
OH, NO.
>> NEED TO GO TO THE BATHROOM,
BUT YOU HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO
DO, AND IT'S ALL THE WAY DOWN
THE HALL.
>> YEP.
>> WE'VE ALL BEEN THERE BEFORE.
WHY DON'T YOU CHECK YOUR LAMP?
>> HUH?
>> CHECK YOUR LAMP.
>> WHOAH.
>> GO AHEAD, DO YOUR BUSINESS.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> USE IT AS A TOILET.
>> OH, NOW I GET IT.
>> INTRODUCING THE UNDERCOVER
OFFICE POTTY, THE ONLY TOILET
THAT LOOKS LIKE A LAMP, SO YOU
CAN GO WHENEVER YOU WANT, AND NO
ONE HAS TO KNOW.
JUST OPEN IT UP AND GO TO TOWN.
IT'LL BE OUR LITTLE SECRET.
>> THANKS UNDER COVER OFFICE
POTTY, I DID GOOD.
>> HEY JOHNSON, DID YOU GET
AROUND TO THOSE REPORTS?
>> YEAH, FINISHED THEM A WHILE
AGO.
I HAD PLENTY OF TIME.
>> WAIT, WHY DO YOU HAVE SO MANY
LAMPS ON YOUR DESK?
>> I GUESS I LIKE A LOT OF
LIGHT.
>> OH, GOD, IT STINKS IN HERE.
>> WELL, IT WASN'T ME, I USED
THE BATHROOM ALL THE WAY DOWN
THE HALL.
>> JESUS, I THINK IT'S THESE
LAMPS.
[ BLEEP ]MAN, IT'S DEFINITELY
THESE LAMPS.
OH MY GOD.
>> SMELLS LIKE REGULAR LAMPS TO
ME.
>> HEY ADAM, GET IN HERE.
>> HOLY [ BLEEP ].
>> ALL RIGHT, EVERYBODY CALM
DOWN.
>> NO, THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG
WITH THESE LAMPS.
>> YEAH RIGHT.
I PROBABLY HAVE TO GET BACK TO
WORK.
>> DUDE, DID YOU TAKE A [ BLEEP
] IN YOUR LAMP?
>> WHAT?
IN THESE LAMPS?
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> WE GOT TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS, I'M TELLING MR. ANDERSON
P.M.
>> NO, PLEASE.
>> JOHNSON, THIS IS NEVER EASY,
BUT YOUR CO-WORKERS ARE
COMPLAINING ABOUT YOUR LAMPS.
>> BUT I GO TO THE BATHROOM ALL
THE WAY DOWN THE HALL.
>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THESE
LAMPS.
OH, MY GOD.
>> YOU LIED JOHNSON.
YOU WENT TO THE BATHROOM IN THE
LAMPS.
GET HIM OUT OF HERE.
>> YES, SIR, SORRY SIR.
>> LET ME GUESS, NOSEY
CO-WORKERS CAUGHT ON TO THE
LAMPS BECAUSE YOU HAD TOO MANY
ON YOUR DESK?
>> YEP.
>> WE'VE YOU COVERED WITH EVERY
DAY OFFICE ITEMS THAT YOU CAN
USE AS A TOILET.
INTRODUCING THE UNDERCOVER
OFFICE POTTY DISGUISE SUPPLIES.
USE THE STAPLER, THE TAPE
DISPENSER, AND THE AUTOMATIC
PENCIL SHARPENER.
>> HEY, GUYS, LOOK, I GOT RID OF
THE LAMPS.
>> WHY IS YOUR TAPE DISPENSER SO
MASSIVE?
>> I GUESS I LIKE A LOT OF TAPE.
>> GUYS, HE'S GOING TO THE
BATHROOM IN THESE OVERSIZED
FAKE OFFICE SUPPLIES.
>> I GO TO THE BATHROOM DOWN THE
HALL.
>> WHAT IS WRONG WITH YOU?
>> WHY WOULD YOU DO THIS?
>> THE VOICEOVER SAID IT WOULD
SAVE TIME FOR BUSINESS.
>> WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN WORKING
ON?
>> I DON'T KNOW, I'VE BEEN TOO
BUSY GOING TO THE BATHROOM.
>> THERE'S SO MUCH [ BLEEP ] IN
HERE.
>> AM I FIRED?
>> YES, AND TAKE THAT [ BLEEP ]
WITH YOU.
>> OF COURSE.
YEAH, OF COURSE.
>> UNDERCOVER OFFICE POTTY, BE
BOLD, BE TRUE.
MAKE THE BATHROOM COME TO YOU.